pas là
ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
cet après-midi la haute assemblée se
penche à nouveau sur les contrats
d'assurance vie non réclamés
il pourrait représenter entre 800
millions d'euros et 5 milliards d'euros
selon un cabinet d'expertisé spécialisé
dans la défense des petits actionnaires
pour hervé maurey sénateur centriste de
l'eure il faut donc renforcer les
obligations des assureurs de rechercher
les bénéficiaires de ces contrats non
réclamés c'est tout le sens de la
proposition de loi qu'il a déposée et
qui est donc discuté cet après midi
bonne séance à tous la séance est
reprise l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
relative aux contrats d'assurance sur la
vie présentée par monsieur hervé maurey
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur hervé maurey auteur de la
proposition de loi
monsieur le président madame la
présidente pardon monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'assurance vie vous savez et
le produit préféré des français en terme
d' épargne sa popularité ne se dément
pas près de 12 millions de nos
concitoyens avait en février 2010
souscrit un contrat d'assurance vie pour
un montant total d'un million deux cent
soixante cinq milliards d'euros c'est à
dire l'équivalent de 80% du pib français
de plus de la moitié de l'encours des
produits départ une longue et davantage
que l'ensemble de la capitalisation
boursière du cac 40
le volume de l'assurance vie ne fait
qu'augmenter puisqu'en 2009 ce sont près
de 5 millions de nouveaux contrats qui
ont été souscrits représentant une
croissance de l'encours global de 12 à
14% selon les estimations en douze ans
l'encours a presque triplé
une ombre plane toutefois sur ce produit
phare de l'épargné française la question
des contrats d'assurance vie non
réclamés au décès de l'assuré
cette question est régulièrement évoqué
depuis maintenant près d'une dizaine
d'années et elle est tout à fait
essentielle car elle touche à la base
même de toute relation contractuelle
tout particulièrement dans le domaine de
l'epagne la confiance il n'est pas
acceptable que des encours soit
conservée par les assureurs alors qu'il
devrait être versée aux bénéficiaires
des contrats
ce n'est pas acceptable d'un point de
vue éthique car le doute ne peut pas
exister en la matière les assurés
doivent être certain que les sommes
versées iront à leurs destinataires
ce n'est pas non plus acceptable d'un
point de vue économique car ces sommes
seraient plus utiles réinjectés dans
l'économie où elles généraient notamment
des recettes fiscales
le législateur a donc été conduit en
2005 a posé un certain nombre un certain
nombre de règles
tout d'abord la possibilité pour toute
personne physique ou morale de se
renseigner auprès de l'agira organisme
créé par cette même loi
de l'éventuelle existence d'une
stipulation sa faveur dans un contrat
d'assurance vie souscrits par une
personne décédée dès lors qu'elles
apportent la preuve de ce décès et sur
proposition de notre collègue yves
détraigne le principe selon lequel la
société d'assurance dès lors qu'elle est
informée du décès de l'assuré et dès
lors qu'elle connaît les coordonnées du
bénéficiaire du contrat doivent en
informer
comment d'ailleurs ne pas s'étonner
qu'il ait fallu inscrire dans la loi
cette mesure de bon sens qui répond me
semble-t-il allèles à l'honnêteté la
plus élémentaire prévenir le
bénéficiaire du décès de l'assuré et de
l'existence d'un contrat en sa faveur
la loi de 2005
si elle constituait un incontestable
progrès étaient encore insuffisantes
aussi le législateur a dû se saisir de
cette question
dès 2007 la loi du 17 décembre 2007
votée à l'unanimité par le sénat oblige
les assureurs à s'informer de l'éventuel
décès des souscripteurs et à rechercher
le cas échéant les bénéficiaires pour
accomplir cette mission et savoir si un
assuré et vivants ou décédés
la loi a ouvert aux assureurs la
possibilité de consulter le répertoire
national d'identification des personnes
physiques
le fameux air est ni pépé elle a
également autorisé les traitements de
données nominatives
issu de ce répertoire en vue de
rechercher les bénéficiaires sans doute
stimulée par ce texte les assureurs se
sont alors engagés à consulter ce
fichier
dès lors que l'assuré est âgé de plus de
90 ans que l'encours de son contrat est
supérieur à 2000 euros et qu'il n'a pas
donné de nouvelles depuis deux ans
ces avancées ont été incontestablement
utile et positive et il convient de les
saluer le sait que le fichier agira de
était et consulté plus de 8 millions de
fois en un an
en atteste et atteste également de
l'importance de ce phénomène
aussi certains se sont interrogés sur
l'utilité de légiférer à nouveau sur
cette question
si j'ai souhaité déposer une proposition
de loi
c'est tout simplement parce que je crois
le dispositif encore perfectible la
célèbre phrase de boileau hâtez-vous
lentement et sans perdre courage vingt
fois sur le métier remettez votre
ouvrage police et le sans cesse et leur
police et semble fait pour ce sujet tant
les réticences rencontre et nécessite de
se hâter lentement mais de ne pas perdre
courage et de remettre sur le métier
l'ouvragé pour le polir et leur polir de
telle sorte à progressivement mettre fin
à la situation scandaleuse que
constituent les assurances vie non
réclamés
je crois de surcroît que légiférer
efficacement ses savoir faire le point
régulièrement sur un dispositif pour le
faire évoluer et l'améliorer
c'est ce que certains appellent
aujourd'hui d'un terme que je n'aime pas
beaucoup même si j'en approuve le
principe la clause de revoyure
j'ajoute qu'à plusieurs reprises le
médiateur de la république qui soutient
notre démarche a souligné que malgré les
évolutions législatives la situation
actuelle n'était pas satisfaisante
les assureurs et les pouvoirs publics je
le cite ne jouant pas le jeu
l'objet de cette proposition de loi est
donc de renforcer les obligations des
assureurs en matière de recherche
puisque comme nous l'avons dit la loi de
2007 et peu contraignantes sur ce
principe et les obligations que les
assureurs se sont fixé eux mêmes sont me
semble-t-il insuffisante
le second objectif de cette proposition
de loi
tout aussi important et d'améliorer la
transparence sur la question des
contrats d'assurance vie non réclamés
votre commission des lois a bien voulu
reconnaître l'utilité de cette
proposition et je l'en remercie
je tiens à saluer son travail et tout
particulièrement celui de son rapporteur
mon collègue dominique de legge sa
capacité d écoute son objectivité et son
pragmatisme ont permis de trouver un
équilibre satisfaisant
si la commission a modifié sensiblement
le texte initial est là je la cite
pleinement souscrit à ces objectifs
et c'est là l'essentiel elle a même été
au delà de ce que je proposais en
prévoyant l'obligation pour les
assureurs de consulter chaque année le
répertoire national d'identification des
personnes physiques
dès lors que l'encours du contrat est
supérieur à 2000 euros et sans plus posé
aucune condition relative à l'âge du
souscripteur
c'est une avancée considérable par
rapport à la situation actuelle et je
tiens à la saluer la commission des lois
a également partagé mes objectifs en
termes de transparence en prévoyant que
les compagnies d'assurances rendre
compte chaque année de leurs recherches
et que les organismes professionnels
publient un bilan de l'application des
dispositifs agira 1 et agira 2 sur
d'autres aspects
mes propositions ne répondaient sans
doute pas aux préceptes de boileau selon
lequel il convient de se hâter lentement
et nécessiteront peut-être d'être
remises sur le métier ultérieurement
je pense à la question de
l'irrévocabilité de la clause
bénéficiaire qui a pour conséquence
qu'un certain nombre d'assurés préfère
ne pas informer les bénéficiaires de
l'existence même du contrat pour pouvoir
s'ils le souhaitent changer librement de
bénéficiaires je sais que ma collègue
catherine trop cassia avait évoqué ce
sujet déjà en 2007
je pense également à la nécessité de
disposer d'un meilleur suivi des assurés
tout au long de leur vie
en s'informant sur l'évolution de leur
situation familiale et matrimoniale ou
sur leur changement d'adressé
car un meilleur suivi permet de
connaître plus aisément le décès de
l'assuré est d'identifier plus
rapidement le bénéficiaire du contrat
à cet égard il serait important d'être
mieux informés sur la question des
haines pays de leur importance et leur
suivi
certains assureurs se sont d'ailleurs
déjà saisi du sujet il soit il serait
souhaitable que la profession dans son
ensemble prennent des engagements
conscient de la qualité du travail de
votre commission
je n'ai donc pas avec mon collègue yves
détraigne et les membres du groupe de
l'union centriste déposé de nombreux
amendements puisque nous n'en avons
déposé que deux le premier et
rédactionnelles et vise simplement à
préciser les obligations des assureurs
en termes d'information sur les
démarches qu'ils auront à effectuer en
application du dispositif proposé par la
proposition de loi le second amendement
et lui d'un amendement de fonds c'est
même un amendement extrêmement
importants puisqu'ils vivent ils visent
à ce que nous connaissions enfin
l'ampleur du phénomène des contrats
d'assurance vie non réclamés
vous savez qu'il existe ce que notre
rapporteur appelle une zone grise
puisque pour certains
le montant des contrats d'assurance-vie
s'élèverait à 700 millions d'euros et
pour d'autres à 5 milliards
je dois vous dire que j'ai quelques
doutes sur l'estimation fournie par les
assureurs puisque ce chiffre de 700
millions d'euros avait déjà été donné il
y a plus de dix ans or on sait qu'ils
concernaient à l'époque uniquement les
assurés de plus de 103 ans ce qui ne
correspond pas tout à fait à l'espérance
de vie actuelle et que de surcroît le
nombre des encours a presque triplé en
dix ans
la réalité est sans doute comme pour les
manifestations quelque part entre le
chiffre des organisateurs est celui de
la préfecture
le médiateur de la république a pour sa
part évoqué plusieurs milliards et jugé
cette situation inacceptable
mais quel que soit le montant réel il
reste trop élevé et il n'est pas
tolérable que nous soyons dans
l'ignorance de l'ampleur du feu
mais c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons et
c'est l'objet de l'amendement du groupe
centriste sortir enfin de l'opacité qui
règne sur cette question sept
amendements que nous présenterons tout à
l'heure prévoit que chaque année l'agira
communique le nombre et les encours des
contrats non réclamés
ainsi nous devrions être enfin
réellement informées et puisque les
assureurs ont déclaré dans la presse ne
rien avoir à cacher je ne vois pas ce
qui pourrait les gêner
voilà monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues ce que je souhaitais vous
indiquer en ce début de discussions
j'espère comme ce fut le cas en 2007 que
notre haute assemblée sera unanime à
voter ce texte
cette unanimité permettra de manifester
avec force notre volonté et notre
exigence en terme de protection des
épargnants et de leurs héritiers est
également en termes de transparence et
de moralisation de notre système
financier
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur dominique de legge rapporteur
de la commission des lois
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois chers collègues
la proposition de loi d'hervé maurey que
nous examinons aujourd'hui a pour
objectif de réduire le nombre des
contrats d'assurance sur la vie en
déshérence et à dire non réclamés par
leurs bénéficiaires
après le décès de l'assuré il s'agit
incontestablement d'un problème dont la
solution et délicates à établir de
manière satisfaisante au mieux situer
l'enjeu rappelons que les contrats
d'assurance vie atteignent un encours de
1265 milliards en 2010 et leur
progression est de l'ordre de 10% par an
c'est 30 millions de contrats
représentent 80% du pib
il est par définition difficile de
connaître le nombre exact des contrats
d'assurance vie non réclamés hors
contrats souscrits dans le cadre des
emprunts
selon les estimations et les personnes
interrogées le montant des encours
concernés se situerait entre 700
millions et 5 milliards d'euros somme
importante qu'il faut néanmoins
rapprochés de l'encours total que
j'évoquais à l'instant 1265 milliards
les raisons pour lesquelles un contrat
n'est pas réclamé tiennent à des
problèmes d'information
l'assureur n'est pas informée du décès
de l'assuré tandis que le bénéficiaire
ignorent qu'à contrat a été souscrit à
son profit ou encore lorsque l'assureur
peine à trouver le bénéficiaire
la loi du 15 décembre 2005 a permis aux
assureurs de se regrouper au travers
d'un organisme dédié l'agira association
pour la gestion des informations
relatives au risque en assurance afin de
créer un guichet unique permettant à
toute personne de s'informer d'existence
d'une stipulation en sa faveur
agira 1 a reçu vingt mille courriers en
2007 26 mille en 2009 depuis sa création
7499 contrats ont été détectés pour un
encours total de 205 millions l'adroit
du 17 décembre 2007 est allé plus loin
imposant aux assureurs l'obligation de
s'informer sur le décès éventuel de
sur et laure donnant la capacité
juridique et technique de procéder à
cette vérification
après l'accès au répertoire national
d'identification des personnes physiques
c'est le dispositif dénommé agira 2 dans
le cadre d'accords nationaux les
assureurs ont convenu de faire porter
prioritairement leur recherche sur les
assurés de plus de 90 ans et sur les
contrats supérieurs à 2000 euros 700
défini par arrêté ministériel s'applique
à l'article l 132 22 du code des
assurances et prévoit une obligation
d'information annuel du souscripteur la
mise en place du dispositif agira 2
nécessité une autorisation préalable de
la cnil qui a été accordé en décembre
les premiers résultats témoignent d'une
forte utilisation
depuis septembre 2009 on recense en
moyenne un million de consultations en
ciel un million six cent soixante deux
mille pour le seul mois d'octobre 2009
déposé moins de deux ans après
l'adoption définitive de la loi du 17
décembre 2007 et moins d'un an après la
mise en place d' agir à 2 la présente
proposition de loi constitue une
nouvelle étape législative son auteur
notre collègue hervé maurey a souhaité
ainsi fort justement renforcer le
dispositif mis en place si la commission
des lois et moi-même adhérents tout à
fait à l'objectif visé par le texte
nous considérons toutefois qu'il
intervient peut-être un peu tôt après la
mise en application effective de la loi
de 2007
nous avons donc souhaité appuyer
l'économie générale des mesures figurant
dans la proposition de loi en prenant
soin de ne pas remettre en cause
l'équilibré atteint par la réforme de
2007 la commission des lois a souhaité à
travers ces amendements d'une part
renforcer les obligations d'information
des assureurs et d'autre part ne pas
revenir sur la réforme de l'acceptation
de la clause bénéficiaire
permettez-moi d'examiner plus en détail
les quatre articles comptait
initialement la proposition de loi
l'ars
le un rang annuel l'obligation de
s'informer de l'éventuel décès de
l'assuré
lorsque celui ci n'a pas accusé
réception de la communication annuelle à
trois reprises consécutives pour des
contrats supérieurs à 2000 euros
cette obligation a semblé trop
restrictive à la commission car elle
permet d'attendre un délai de trois ans
sans accusé de réception avant que
l'assureur ait obligation de procéder à
la vérification du décès éventuel de
l'assuré et ce quel que soit son âge
depuis l'entrée en vigueur d'agir à 2
les assureurs ont déjà procédé au
contrôle des contrats pour lesquels la
provision mathématique étaient
supérieurs à 2000 euros l'assuré âgées
depuis de 90 ans sans contact avec lui
depuis au moins deux ans nous avons jugé
souhaitable d'aller plus loin
de manière plus simple et plus
systématiques entrevoyant une obligation
annuelle de consultation du répertoire
national dudit faute d'identification
pour tous les contrats dont la provision
est supérieur à 2000 euros et sans
condition d'âge l'article 1 impose
également une obligation de recherche du
bénéficiaire du contrat lorsqu'il
apparaît à l'issue de la recherche que
l'assuré n'est pas décédé mais qu'il n'a
pas accusé réception à trois reprises
consécutives pour la même objection de
l'odeur matériel nous n'avons pas retenu
cette mesure
en troisième lieu la proposition de loi
propose d'imputer les frais de recherche
de l'éventuel décès de l'assuré sur le
bénéficiaire nous avons considéré qu'il
était injustifié de faire peser sur le
bénéficiaire des coûts dont il n'est pas
responsable
une telle disposition ouvrirait la porte
à des dérives très pénalisante pour les
bénéficiaires par le prélèvement de
frais injustifiées
il appartient en ôta l'assureur de
vérifier que la clause bénéficiaire du
contrat a été rédigé de manière
suffisamment claire pour que le
bénéficiaire puisse est aisément
retrouver la commission a donc écarté
cette disposition
enfin l'article premier prévoit la
publication annuelle par les assureurs
d'un état indiquant le nombre et
l'encours des contrats non réclamés
répondant aux critères de montant de
1000 euros et d'âge plus de 90 ans
une telle obligation de transparence ne
nous a pas semblé véritablement
opérationnel nous avons préféré créer en
insérant un article 1er bis au tec une
obligation d'annexer aux comptes annuels
un état des démarches effectuées au type
d'agir à 1 et 2 et là encore quel que
soit l'âge du souscripteur
il va de souci de transparence qui
évoquait à l'instant notre collègue mort
est un article de ou des formalités
lourde et coûteuse de communication
annuelle par le souscripteur à
l'assureur de changement d'adressé
d'accusé de réception sont prévues la
commission à ce préféré supprimer ces
dispositions là encore dans un souci de
simplification et compte tenu des
modifications que je viens d'évoquer qui
mettait en place un système plus
systématique
c'est le même raisonnement qui a valu à
l'article 3 qui prévoyait l'intervention
de tiers agréé pour la recherche des
bénéficiaires
enfin l'article 4 qui n'est pas tout à
fait de même nature
le caractère irrévocable de la
souscription de la stipulation faux
souscripteur d'un ratio d'un contrat
d'assurance-vie en faveur du
bénéficiaire du contrat nous a semblé
une remise en cause très significative
de l' équilibre de la loi de 2007
voici mes chers collègues les grandes
lignes des propositions faites par la
commission des lois
nous avons bien entendu travailler en
étroite concertation et dans la plus
grande transparence avec notre collègue
hervé maurey dont je salue ici le
travail l'écoutent et la compétence
notre souci principal avant d'envisager
toute nouvelle disposition était de ne
pas compliquer ni alourdir les
dispositifs agira 1 et 2 déjà
opérationnel et dont les effets semblent
positifs le sujet des assurances vie non
réclamés est un sujet sensible
particulièrement en un temps où
l'espérance de vie ne cesse de
s'allonger
il méritait notre examen le plus
attentif en conclusion je ne sous estime
pas le débat sur ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler les contrats non réclamés ou
en déshérence force est de reconnaître
que ces contrats sont source de
suspicion quant à leur nom
en remontant et leur origine
l'initiative de notre collègue hervé
maurey replacer dans l'esprit de la loi
2007 a le grand mérite de dépasser ce
débat en s'attachant à l'aspect
pragmatique du sujet il s'agit en effet
de réduire le phénomène en
perfectionnant les dispositifs existants
plutôt que de chercher à définir ce
qu'est un contrat tombé en déshérence
nous nous sommes attachés à faire en
sorte que chaque contrat finissent par
trouver son bénéficiaire
tel est l'objet poursuivi par la
commission des lois et qui inspirait la
réflexion de votre rapporteur
je vous remercie de votre attention la
parole est à monsieur hervé novelli
secrétaire d'état chargé du commerce de
l'artisanat des petites et moyennes
entreprises du tourisme des services et
de la consommation
bonjour monsieur minutes l'âme le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
cette proposition de loi et même est
maintenant de desmaures et de membres du
groupe centriste me semble bienvenue
elle est bienvenue tente les contrats
non réclamés
leurs montants font l'objet de
supputations et parfois de fantasmes sur
cette sorte de trésor de monte cristo
qu'il s'agirait de mettre à jour ce
trésor
nous avons vu que du reste il était
assez difficile à évaluer
700 millions d'euros d'un côté 5
milliards d'euros de l'autre et je
voudrais tout de suite dire combien
l'effort de transparence que la
proposition de loi tend à mettre en
oeuvre mais aussi le travail de la
commission des lois
avoir comme efficacité première
d'instaurer cette transparence tout à
fait nécessaire car la transparence
c'est un des piliers de la confiance
en juin 2008 la profession de
l'assurance publiait un baromètre de
l'image de l'assurance en france ce
baromètre montrait que pour un français
sur deux secteurs de l'assurance est
synonyme de confiance
cette confiance m'apparaît essentiel
pour deux raisons la première comme l'a
très bien dit hervé maurey c'est que
l'assurance vie est aujourd'hui le
produit d'épargné préféré des français
la confiance est impérative pour un
produit qui concerne 22 millions de
contrats et près de 41% du patrimoine
financier des ménages s'agit donc là
d'un enjeu important de consommation
auquel je suis évidemment
particulièrement sensible compte tenu de
mes responsabilités ministérielles dans
ce domaine la deuxième raison est que
l'assurance vie ne peut tout simplement
pas exister sans confiance car au moment
du décès de l'assuré c'est l'assureur
qui a la responsabilité de verser les
sommes aux bénéficiaires et l'existence
d'un stock tu reste difficile à évaluer
on le sait de contrats non réclamés est
un échec
à cet égard la profession de l'assurance
a je crois pleinement pris conscience de
cet enjeu qui est devenu une priorité de
ses engagements déontologiques
pour autant la confiance n'exclut pas de
réguler et cette régulation elle est
même indispensable je le crois pour
renforcer cette confiance là encore
c'est le rôle du secrétaire d'état à la
consommation que d'y veiller avec
d'autres acteurs bien sûr depuis trois
ans les pouvoirs publics le gouvernement
a travaillé à renforcer les conditions
de la confiance entre assureurs et
assurés au bénéfice des consommateurs
on n'y a fait référence aux orateurs
précédents l'on fait la loi du 17
décembre 2007 constitue de ce point de
vue
une avancée décisive autour de trois
actions clés l'information là le moyen
données aux assureurs de s'informer et
la recherche a opéré par les assureurs
vers les bénéficiaires informer d'abord
la loi de décembre 2007 oblige les
assureurs à s'informer du décès de leurs
assurés avant de pouvoir verser des
sommes aux bénéficiaires
l'assureur doit s'informer du décès de
l'assuré c'est ce que prévoit la loi
la loi donne ensuite aux assureurs les
moyens de s'informer
depuis mars 2009 les assureurs ont accès
au fichier national qui recense les
décès le répertoire national
d'identification des personnes privées
ou rn ip p la loi oblige enfin les
assureurs à rechercher les bénéficiaires
une fois qu'ils ont connaissance du
décès de l'assuré
toujours dans la loi de 2007
nous avons voulu réformer la clause
bénéficiaire dont on a parlé pour la
rendre plus juste
cette clause pouvait se retourner contre
l'assuré quand le bénéficiaire était
informé de l'existence du contrat
ils pouvaient alors accepter la clause
la rendant ainsi irrévocable et privant
l'assuré de toute possibilité de jouir
de ces fonds le cas échéant à son insu
ou contre son gré la loi à réformer le
fonctionnement de la clause bénéficiaire
et l'assuré peut désormais informer sans
crainte ce dernier la sécurité des
consommateurs est renforcée et informer
le bénéficiaire est encore la meilleure
garantie que le contrat sera réclamée au
décès de l'assuré
ces nouvelles mesures sont venus
compléter la loi de 2005 qui on le sait
permet à tout particulier qui pensent
avoir été désigné comme bénéficiaire
d'un contrat d'assurance de se le faire
confirmer en faisant une demande unique
à l'association agir à qui saisit à son
tour l'ensemble des assureurs
parlons un peu de l'efficacité de ces
dispositifs je crois que celle ci cette
efficacité est aujourd'hui démontrée le
gouvernement a publié en juin 2009 un
rapport relatives aux contrats
d'assurance vie non réclamés en trois
ans et demi
le dispositif agira 1 de la loi de 2005
a permis grâce aux demandes de
particuliers qui pensaient bénéficiaires
de contrats d'assurance-vie d'ouvrir
sept mille cinq cents dossiers
représentant de 105 millions d'euros de
capitaux a versé en 2009 le dispositif
agira 2 de la loi de 2007 qui permet aux
assureurs de consulter le fichier
national des décès a été comme l'a dit
hervé maurey fortement utilisés par les
assureurs avec plus de 6 millions
d'interrogation 6 millions
d'interrogation c'est évidemment
considérable ces interrogations ont
permis à leur tour l'identification de
14 mille décès ce qui a entraîné le
versement de 121 millions d'euros
supplémentaires au final grâce à ses
deux dispositifs agira 1 et agira 2 ce
sont près de 330 millions d'euros qui
ont retrouvé leur chemin en direction
des consommateurs
alors aujourd'hui la proposition de loi
présentée par le sénateur hervé maurey
nous donne à la fois l'occasion de faire
le point sur agir à ce que je viens de
dire
mais aussi de parfaire les dispositifs
existants votre commission des lois a
s'est livré un véritable travail
d'orfèvre sous les mines hommes
présidence évidemment de jean jacques
hyest mais aussi le remarquable travail
je veux le dire de dominique de legge
pour identifier à la fois les
insuffisances du dispositif de 2007 mais
tout en s'inscrivant résolument dans la
continuité des dispositifs agira qui
sont en train de faire leurs preuves et
c'est cela je croirais vous l'avez très
bien dit monsieur le rapporteur
l'intérêt de la proposition de loi que
de se couler dans les dispositifs
existants qui démontre peu à peu
une efficacité grandissante je voulais
vraiment remercier la commission des
lois et son rapporteur le texte de votre
commission va tout d'abord jusqu'au bout
de la logique de la loi de 2007 en
proposant d'imposer une obligation
annuelle pour les assureurs de croiser
leurs fichiers d'assurer avec le fichier
national des décès il acte ensuite ce
texte formellement un principe de
responsabilité des assureurs qui n'est
pas démentie par la pratique observée
depuis la loi de 2007 en exigeant des
assureurs qu'ils publient chaque année
les démarches qu'ils ont entreprises
pour rechercher les bénéficiaires de
contrats non réclamés ainsi que les
résultats de ces démarches
moi je crois que ce sont là des avancées
à la fois de bon sens qui prolonge la
loi de 2007 qui sont efficaces et qui
sont proportionnées tout cela porte la
marque de l'action de la commission des
lois du sénat
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement jeu le 10
sera favorable au texte issu des travaux
de votre commission
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur thierry foucaud pour le groupe
crc spg
bien madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
porte sur une question que nous avions
dans un passé d'ailleurs récemment
relativement récent déjà eu l'occasion
de traiter
il n'en demeure pas moins que de temps à
autre une discussion sur l'état
d'avancement est de mise en oeuvre de
telles ou telles dispositions
législatives n'est pas forcément
malvenue l'assurance vie constitue un
des placements préférés des français et
au delà du flux annuel des versements
réalisés par les ménages épargnent ans
le montant des sommes pour l'heure
capitaliser s'avère je dirais
particulièrement significatif il dépasse
en effet les 1200 milliards d'euros et 2
par les choix prioritaires
d'investissements réalisés par les
compagnies d'assurances gestionnaires de
ces contrats cette situation amène nos
compatriotes être détenteur d'une part
importante de la dette de l'état puisque
le marché obligataire est largement
sollicitée par les opérateurs du secteur
il conviendrait d'ailleurs le moment
venu de s'interroger sur l'entourage
fiscale de ce placement vedette
quelle assurance vie puisque celui ci a
été profondément modifiée que les
mesures tendant à restreindre les
avantages fiscaux associés à la
souscription n'ont pas réellement
ralenti le mouvement de souscription
toujours est il que le succès de ce
placement quelle assurance vie comporte
quelques contreparties qui sont moins
connus et notamment le fait que les
souscriptions
les souscripteurs ne sont pas toujours
mis très jeunes ni très fortunés et
qu'une partie des contrats à capitaliser
se retrouve finalement en déshérence
tranches ont d'ailleurs d'entrée de la
question des montants en jeu
une question sur laquelle tout le monde
peut considérer avoir raison ou avoir
tort c'est à dire que l'on pourrait
retenir autant l'estimation basse 800
millions d'euros selon les
professionnels de l'assurance que
l'estimation haute
5 milliards d'euros
selon certains cabinets ou associations
je dirais spécialisés dans l'appui aux
bénéficiaires de contrats à la recherche
de leur capital à vrai dire il est sans
doute difficile d'avoir une estimation
précise à leurs prêts en ce sens que le
suivi des contrats par les compagnies
d'assurances elle-même semble bel et
bien souffrir d'une incapacité à
retracer à un moment donné l'ensemble du
capital des contrats en déshérence
la proposition de loi dans ses
intentions s'est orientée d'emblée vers
un renforcement des voies et moyens
permettant la récupération des contrats
non réclamés mais elle l'a fait de
manière en grande partie j'irai peu à
peu approprié puisqu'il a même été
question de donner aux compagnies
d'assurance la possibilité d'imputer sur
le capital finalement restituer les
coûts explosent et pour retrouver les
bénéficiaires de la liquidation du
contrat
je constate à la lecture du rapport
comme du texte de la commission des lois
que ces dispositions étaient
heureusement retirée du texte soumis à
examen car en ces matières il convient
de garder raison
attendu en effet que les sommes
récupérées par les bénéficiaires sont en
moyenne d'un montant réduit un peu plus
de 8600 euros
une telle démarche pour peu que les
détectives de l'assurance je dirais
forfaitisés leur intervention aurait
privé les bénéficiaires les plus
modestement dotée d'une part importante
du maigre capital à récupérer et à dire
vrai le passage de la proposition de loi
en commission aura au moins permis de
pointer les limites fixées aux
intentions de l'auteur même du texte
selimi tiennent en fait à déquilibre
même du texte qui tendait en réalité
c'est notre avis alléger les règles
imposées aux assureurs pour ce qui est
du suivi et de la recherche des
bénéficiaires de contrats bien sûr
d'assurance vie et à leur permettre
accessoirement d'externaliser une partie
de leurs coûts normaux de fonctionnement
sur le dos
des assurés car il s'agit bien de cela
la proposition de loi original visé sous
des apparences bien sûr sympathique
ne serait ce qu'à la lecture de l'exposé
des motifs non pas à s'alarmer de la
situation des contrats non réclamés mais
bien à donner aux assurances une plus
grande latitude dans la gestion courante
de ces contrats que voulez vous quand on
prévoir et que c'est au bout de trois
ans des missions d'un accusé de
réception à fructueux qu'on décide de
mettre en oeuvre la démarche prévue par
l'actuel cadre légistatives on laisse
donc trois années à la libre disposition
des compagnies pour user et abuser des
sommes en sommeil le texte donc adopté
par la commission des lois a fixé un
cadre plus pertinent pour la présente
proposition de loi il crée notamment une
obligation de résultat quand chaque
compagnie d'assurances où chaque
mutuelle gestionnaire de produits de
prévoyance
quant à la recherche et à la détection
des contrats non réclamés
une telle orientation ne peut me
semble-t-il que recevoir un avis
favorable de la plus grande partie des
membres de notre assemblée
il va sans dire que nous ne nous
opposerons pas à l'adoption de ce texte
sous la forme définie par la commission
saisie au fond ce qui nous importe et
cela en dernière instance est en effet
que les assurés les bénéficiaires qui
l'ont désigné puisse finalement retrouvé
la pleine disposition de ce qui aura été
le plus souvent pour des montants pour
le moins réduit épargné tout au long
d'une vie de travail
la parole est à monsieur yves détraigne
1 pour le groupe union centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition que nous examinons
aujourd'hui et devrait du moins je
l'espère permettre de boucler le
dispositif qui s'est progressivement mis
en place depuis 2005 pour régler ce
fameux problème des contrats d'assurance
vie non réclamés comme ça a été rappelé
on estime aujourd'hui qu'il x qu'il
existe 22 millions de contrats
d'assurance vie correspondant environ 12
millions de souscripteurs et
représentant un encours total de plus
d'un milliard deux cents millions
d'euros ce qui si je suis bien informé
représente environ deux fois la
capitalisation boursière du cac 40 ayant
pas une petite
les enjeux ne sont donc pas masse mais
comment c'est également un certain
nombre de ces contrats ne font pas
l'objet du versement effectif à leurs
bénéficiaires des sommes qui leur sont
dues en vertu de la volonté du
souscripteur et à la suite de son décès
tout simplement parce que nombre de
bénéficiaires ignorent qu'un contrat a
été ceci à leur profit et ne font donc
aucune réclamation
cela pose un problème à la fois
juridique et morale juridique parce que
l'une des stipulations du contrat est me
semble-t-il une destination essentiel
dans l'esprit du ductus souscripteurs
n'est pas respectée et moral moral parce
que les sommes placées sur ses produits
par les souscripteurs ne l'ont pas été
pour rester dans les réserves des
compagnies d'assurance au delà de leur
décès mais bien pour bénéficier à une
personne qu'ils avaient eux-mêmes choisi
cette problématique a été soulevé une
première fois en 2005 s'était dit devant
notre assemblée au travers d'un
amendement dont j'étais l'auteur et qui
avaient été déposées au moment de la
discussion d'un projet de loi
d'adaptation au droit communautaire dans
le domaine de l'assurance
cet amendement complétée par une
précision souhaité par le gouvernement
et adoptée par notre assemblée a
instauré l'objet
a sion pour l'assureur lorsqu'il est
informé et du décès de l'assuré
d'informer le bénéficiaire d'une
assurance vie de la stipulation effet qu
à son profit si toutefois ces
coordonnées sont portées au contrat
c'est peu de chose comme 10 et hervé
maurey tout à l'heure c'est bien la
moindre des choses mais encore
fallait-il que la loi le dise le
mécanisme introduit en 2005 a ensuite
été complétée en 2007 notamment par une
disposition qui a donné aux sociétés
mutuelles d'assurances les moyens
d'identifier les contrats sur lesquels
ils sont tenus de verser un capital et à
renforcer les obligations moyen qui
pesait sur elle pour d'une part
identifier les bénéficiaires et d'autre
part versé les sommes dues dans un délai
maximal d'un mois à la suite de ces
diverses dispositions les assureurs ont
mis en place l'association pour la
gestion des informations relatives au
risque en assurance l'âge rock la giro
qui a déjà été évoqué et qui joue en
quelque sorte un rôle de guichet unique
pour répondre aux obligations de gestion
et de recherche mises à leur charge et
sony se sont par ailleurs engagés à
procéder à des recherches sur des
contrats dont la sueur et étages et cela
a été dit de plus de 90 ans et pour
lequel il n'y avait pas eu de contact
depuis deux ans c'est un début on va
dire ce dispositif qui va
incontestablement dans le bon sens
nécessaire frais lmnp opérationnelle que
depuis l'an dernier mais on constate
aujourd'hui que le fichier des personnes
décédées qui en a résulté donne lieu à
près d'un million d'interrogation chaque
mois pas tout à fait mais pas loin le
dispositif mis en place à partir de
limites 5 améliorer en 2007 monte donc
en puissance et il n'y a probablement
pas lieu de modifier en procédant en
profondeur ce qui se met en place ne
reste pas moins vrai que le système peut
être amélioré puisque l'on estime fin
2009 qu'il existait un encours de
contrats non réclamés variant entre 700
millions d'euros et près de 5 milliards
quand il y à un tel écart sur les
chiffres on peut dire qu'il ya quand
même
on peut progresser semble-t-il le
travail qui a été fait par la commission
des lois à partir de la proposition de
notre collègue hervé maurey va dans le
bon sens la commission n'a pas souhaité
modifier sensiblement le dispositif mis
en place en 2005 et 2007 notamment je le
disais déjà il ya deux jours à cette
tribune comme nous examinions le projet
de loi tendant à renforcer les moyens de
contrôle du parlement notamment parce
qu'il faut prendre le temps de
l'évaluation
avant de modifier une disposition
législative mais aussi parce que
l'assurance vie est un produit d'épargné
attractifs et que si l'on veut qu'il le
demeure
il convient de lui assurer une certaine
stabilité
celle n'a pas retenu l'ensemble des
dispositions initiales de la proposition
de loi la commission sous la houlette de
son rapporteur dominique de legge a
néanmoins suivi son auteur sur plusieurs
des me des mesures qu'il propose est tel
que l'obligation annuelle de contrôle de
l'éventuel décès de l'assuré d'autant
que les chiffres de consultation du
dispositif que j'évoquais à l'instant
montre que les assureurs sont bien en
mesure de procéder à des recherches
massives sur le portefeuille de leurs
clients ou telles que l'obligation faite
aux assureurs de publier annuellement un
état sur les démarches effectuées pour
la recherche d assurer des cd et des
bénéficiaires des contrats d'assurance
vie ces dispositions vont dans le sens
d'une plus grande transparence sur la
situation de l'assurance vie qui on le
voit au travers de l'approximation des
chiffres que j'évoquais n'est pas
aujourd'hui des plus clairs cela évitera
par ailleurs que se développent comme le
disait le ministre un certain nombre de
fantasmes ou de rumeurs c'est dans le
même esprit que j'ai cosigné les
amendements qui ont été proposées par
hervé maurey qui vont dans le même sens
et qui tendent à compléter l'information
annuel prévu à l'article 1er bis de la
proposition tout état de cause je pense
que les échanges qui ont lieu entre
auteur de la proposition et le
rapporteur et les échanges qui ont eu
lieu en commission des lois sont de
nature à parvenir un texte qui concilie
au mieux transparence et efficacité je
dirais que ce sont deux termes qui
devraient être notre ligne de conduite
sur la plupart des textes que que nous
examinons je souhaite donc nos débats de
ce jour permettent d'adopter une loi qui
garantisse cette transparence sur les
actions menées pour régler au mieux les
problèmes da contre de contrats
d'assurance vie non réclamés aussi bien
du côté des assureurs que du côté des
bénéficiaires
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
virginie klès apparenté socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
monsieur morais a pour but de
s'inquiéter du sort réservé à l'épargné
acquise par certains assurés qui
disparaissent tandis que les
bénéficiaires désignés eun obtiennent
pas le bénéfice des sommes déposées
faute de les avoir réclamé ou tout
simplement faute d'en avoir une
connaissance
nous sommes donc là face à la fois un
problème d'éthique des tic
il s'agit bel et bien de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour voir un voeu s'exaucer le
voeu de l'assuré défunt qui était de
transmettre
mais c'est aussi un problème économique
puisqu'il s'agit aussi de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour voir toutes ces sommes
réinjectée dans le circuit économique
le dispositif d'épargnants cher aux
français
ce dispositif d'epargne cher aux
français met en relation trois parties
les assureurs
bien évidemment les assurés qui sont
souvent confondus dans les propos des
uns ou des autres avec les souscripteurs
même si effectivement dans la réalité
ils sont souvent confondus et les
bénéficiaires
ces trois partis ont bien évidemment des
intérêts soit divergent soit pas tout à
fait convergent en tout cas différent en
ce qui concerne les assureurs il est
bien évident que leur intérêt n'est pas
de reverser cet argent mais de le
conserver et de le faire fructifier le
plus longtemps possible en ce qui
concerne les assurés ou les
souscripteurs
il me semble qu'il ne faut tout de même
pas oublier que leur intérêt puisqu'il
s'agit là d'un dispositif d'épargné
reste de conserver une certaine maîtrise
de ce capital de pouvoir éventuellement
changer de bénéficiaire au gré de la vie
et de ses événements ou même
éventuellement de racheter ou de
récupérer une part tout ou partie du
capital et c'est un point qu'il ne faut
pas négliger dans nos discussions
le bénéficiaire bien évidemment lui son
intérêt et de bénéficier son droit donc
d'abord de son droit donc d'abord d'en
être informé puis de pouvoir l'exercer
ça a déjà été souligné par les
précédents orateurs
nous sommes tous un peu choqués d'abord
par la non transparence sur ces contrats
en déshérence notamment en matière de
somme 700 millions d'euros 1,5 milliard
d'euros la différence est quand même de
taille et c'est vrai que ce manque de
transparence n'incite pas bien
évidemment à la confiance et à des
relations mieux établis entre les uns et
des autres ce qui semble anormal aussi
c'est qu'effectivement les assureurs
puissent gérer pendant trente ans de
l'argent qu'il leur appartient pas alors
que cet argent à un bénéficiaire
potentiel qui simplement n'est pas
informée ou n'a pas trouvé le moyen de
venir réclamer cet argent qui lui dit du
pardon depuis 2005 pour autant la
situation a bien évolué c'est vrai 2005
2006 2007 ce sont des dates qui sont qui
sont revenus assez souvent aussi dans
les propos des orateurs précédents la
mise en place de dispositifs agira 1 qui
a ouvert la possibilité à tous
bénéficiaires potentiels de s'informer
sur ces droits éventuels étaient
effectivement une première avancée les
dispositions sur l'acceptation de la
clause bénéficiaire qui ne peut plus se
faire à l'insu du souscripteur qui doit
se faire forcément avec son accord qui a
sans doute aussi permis d'améliorer
l'information des bénéficiaires et puis
le dispositif agira 2 beaucoup plus
récemment sur lequel on encore
relativement peu de recul quant au
résultat qui entraîne des obligations
pour l'assureur lui-même d'interroger
les red bee est de refaire le point sur
ces fichiers
on peut aussi souligner au passage des
incitations fortes pour les assureurs à
verser des fonds rapidement une fois
qu'ils ont retrouvé les bénéficiaires
sous peine de ce que j'appelle des
pénalités entre guillemets en tout cas
des versements d'intérêts
supplémentaires tout ça a permis
d'installer un certain équilibre dont on
a parlé plusieurs fois aujourd'hui au
moins en tout cas d'améliorer les choses
la proposition de loi notre collègue mon
rêve va dans le même sens d'augmenter
encore les avancées de les améliorer
notamment avec le dispositif agira de
même si effectivement il faudra sans
doute attendre l'avis de la cnil mais le
fait de rendre la consultation annuelle
est obligatoire par les assureurs sans
attendre l'e3 recommandé ou les trois
informations non revenu qui est très
importante l'abolition de la limite
d'âge aussi ne pas s'intéresser qu'aux
contrats souscrits par des personnes de
plus de 90 ans qui était qui a été
soulignée sont effectivement des
avancées intéressantes
la transparence aussi qui va être
améliorée avec la publication tant des
démarches faites par les assureurs que
des sommes des contrats encore en cours
autrement dit au fil des ans on aura un
meilleur regard tant sur le stock de ces
contrats en déshérence que sur leflux
donc on aura une idée effectivement de
l'efficacité des démarches entreprises
par les assureurs donc c'est vrai que
cette proposition de loi amènera
certainement à mieux d'autant plus que
nous attendons avec impatience la
parution du prochain rapport sur
l'ensemble de ceux de ce dossier il
reste pourtant quand même un petit peu
des freins et des propositions qui
auraient pu aller plus loin j'ai deux
pour ma part écouter un certain nombre
d'assureurs qui sont pour beaucoup
d'entre eux très proches de leurs
assurés et qui m'ont suggéré certaines
voies d'amélioration qu'on pourra
rediscuter par la suite puisque je pense
que le sujet reviendra encore à l'ordre
du jour plus d'une fois il est dommage
par exemple d'avoir complètement
supprimé l'article 2 c'est un petit peu
dommage parce que je pense que ça aurait
été une bonne chose que de maintenir la
communication annuelle obligatoire entre
l'assureur et sont assurés je pense que
c'est toujours une bonne chose que de
rappeler à l'assuré qu'il boit mettre à
jour son adresse même si on ne peut pas
lui en tenir rigueur s'il ne le fait pas
je pense qu'il est toujours intéressant
de plus rappelé qu'il peut changer les
bénéficiaires désignés sur son contrat
dépendent tant qu'il n'y a pas de clause
acceptation des bénéficiaires ont signé
il est important aussi de l'informer sur
le montant de son épargne et la une
d'être simple suffisait donc l'article 2
plutôt que d'être supprimée aurait
peut-être pu être un peu modifié dans ce
sens là sur les obligations de
l'assureur qui concerne la formule de la
clause bénéficiaire
il aurait peut-être est intéressant
aussi de pousser les choses plus loin
peut-être au delà de la formule
classique sur les enfants nés ou à
naître ou à défaut les héritiers
autrement dit les ayant droits pour
lesquels en général est assez facile de
s'y retrouver
à partir du moment où c'est une autre
personne qui est nommée bénéficiaires il
aurait pu être intéressant de faire
préciser nom prénom ainsi que date et
lieu de naissance ce qui permettrait à
près de retrouver plus facilement le
bénéficiaire donc serait faciliter les
recherches
lors de la disparition de l'assuré sur
le npa y dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
je ne suis plus qu'à l'orateur on a en a
parlé mais les aime pays représentent
une proportion très importante de
disparition d'information par rapport
aux bénéficiaires
aujourd'hui ils en payent reviennent à
l'assureur pourquoi ne pas imaginer un
dispositif tel les impôts par exemple d'
enveloppe préparer ou quand l'assuré
n'habite plus à l'adresse indiquée ça ne
revient pas l'assureur mais ça
reviendrait par exemple à la girafe qui
pourrait être chargé de faire les
premières recherches plus on recherche
tous une personne qui a changé la bresse
y compris annuellement et plus on a de
chances de la retrouver de la cire et
donc de ne pas la perdre
donc ça pourrait être quelque chose qui
serait intéressant et qui sera discutée
puisqu'on parle de recherche pourquoi
même si je pense fondamentalement que le
financement de la recherche doit
effectivement incomber aux assureurs
mais est ce qu'ils ne voudraient pas
transférer la responsabilité du résultat
de la compagnie d'assurance un autre
organisme
et pourquoi pas par exemple la jirs a
financé une fois de plus par les
assureurs est financé à la difficulté
des recherches autrement dit les
assureurs auraient tout intérêt dans un
système comme celui là à ce que les
recherches aboutissent et vite parce qu
on leur demanderait moins d'argent
maintiendrait la mutualisation de ses
coûts de recherche sur l'ensemble des
contrats on laissera la charge
financière à l'assureur
mais on
transfert à une fois plus la
responsabilité du résultat à une autre
entité qu'à la compagnie d'assurances
elle-même sur la clause du bénéficiaire
acceptant je pense qu'il est important
aussi si on va encore améliorer
l'information des bénéficiaires redonner
peut-être un peu de droit à l'assuré aux
contractants
pourquoi lui redonner du droit parce que
très souvent ces contrats d'assurance
pas très souvent en tout cas souvent
peuvent être effectivement un contrat
c'est à dire que l'assurance et une
garantie ou est donné en échange de
créances aux bénéficiaires dans ce cas
là effectivement on est bien sûr un
contrat avec des engagements réciproques
il me paraît effectivement utile dans ce
cas là que cette forme des pinceaux est
aussi un contrat et qu'on ne puisse pas
revenir sur la clause bénéficiaire mais
comme le bénéficiaire est simplement un
récipiendaire canteleu là sur l'assuré
est simplement un donneur pourquoi ne
pas lui laisser le droit de revenir sur
sa décision
donc il ya certainement là des choses
aussi améliorée en matière d'obligation
d'information du bénéficiaire
sans forcément qu'il y ait
systématiquement cette notion de droit
de contrats pardon entre l'assuré et
et le bénéficiaire parce
qu'effectivement là on ne peut plus rien
changer et l'assuré ne peut plus changer
d'avis en cours de en cours de route est
en cours d'existence et pourtant dieu
sait que la vie peut être riche de
rebondissements et entraîner des
changements d'orientation de l'assuré
donc en conclusion le régime de
l'assurance vie a beaucoup évolué depuis
2005 en avait sans doute besoin
je pense qu'on aurait pu aller sans
doute un petit peu plus loin dans les
contraintes notamment en matière de
résultat vis-à-vis des assureurs et
qu'on aurait peut-être pu être un peu
plus protecteur pour l'assurer en
matière de conservation de droit sur son
capital et sur son épargne
je ne reprendrai pas les citations de
mon collègue mort et mais j'y vis j'y
adhère en tout cas sur le fait qu'il
faudra certainement remettre encore le
travail sur le l'établi néanmoins le
texte tel que présenté tel que modifié
il nous semble tout de même avant faire
avancer les choses
donc pour ces raisons et dans la tente
de la suite des événements et notamment
du prochain rapport promis par le
gouvernement
nous voterons pour ce texte merci madame
la sénatrice
la parole est à monsieur jacques mézard
pour le rdse
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues récupérer
son épargne n'est pas un privilège mais
l'exécution d'un contrat selon les
principes du droit civil
monsieur le ministre vous avez rappelé
qu' un français sur deux finalement
faisait confiance aux assureurs pense
pas que ce soit quand même un résultat
merveilleux ça se discute monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
c'est exact mais nous savions qu'il
existe des niches fiscales très
controversé cependant incluses dans les
lois de finances nous constatons qu'il
existe des niches d'assurance à hauteur
de plusieurs milliards d'euros
tunis vous avez parlé de fantasmes j'ai
même entendu trésor de monte cristo la
différence c'est que le trésor ne monte
cristo il a été retrouvé et que là nous
sommes à la recherche de quelques
trésors
donc cette question qui est aujourd'hui
celle des contrats d'assurance vie non
réclamés par leurs bénéficiaires à la
suite du décès de l'assuré est vraiment
importante de par le montant
considérable des sommes en jeu et je
salue le travail de l'auteur de la
proposition de la commission et du
rapporteur sur ce texte que nous
voterons unanimement au sein de mon
groupe
ce phénomène ne devrait concerner en
principe qu'une faible partie des
encours des contrats d'assurance sur la
vie dans la mesure où ce type
d'assurance étant utilisé comme produit
l'epargne les fonds ont vocation dans la
plupart des cas à revenir aux
souscripteurs cependant contrats
d'assurance sur la vie repose sur le
mécanisme de la stipulation pour autrui
et de ce fait il ne constitue pas un
simple produit d'épargné mais également
un moyen de verser au profit d'un
bénéficiaire un capital ou une rente en
cas de décès donc le texte que nous
examinons prévoir un renforcement des
obligations des sociétés d'assurance et
c'est une très bonne chose
pour rendre effectif le versement des
sommes dues au titre de l'assurance vie
pour garantir les droits des assurés et
des bénéficiaires le rapporteur
l'auteur de la proposition à a parlé de
situation scandaleuse et je crois qu'il
a parfaitement raison en tout cas il y a
un fort besoin de transparence est tout
simplement il faut le dire de
déontologie comme il le fut évoquée
précédemment
c'est un phénomène qui demeure par
définition difficile à quantifier avec
précision ce qui est parfaitement
regrettable parce qu'on prend beaucoup
plus de soin et il ya beaucoup plus de
travail souvent pour rechercher dans
d'autres cas les sommes qui
éventuellement ne sont pas utilisés ou
ou disparaissent s'agit-il de contrats
non réclamés
du fait de la non connaissance du décès
de l'assuré ou de la non connaissance
d'un tel contrat par le bénéficiaire
s'agit-il de difficultés
d'identification ou de localisation du
bénéficiaire
on le voit les difficultés rencontrées
nécessite la prise en compte des
spécificités de chaque cas est pour une
large part cela résulte de l'ignorance
par les bénéficiaires de la stipulation
fait à leur profit en effet
l'acceptation de cette stipulation ayant
un caractère irrévocable
le souscripteur hésitent souvent à faire
connaître son intention aux
bénéficiaires préférant la maintenir
secrète pour conserver la libre
disposition des sommes capitaliser dans
ces conditions sauf à retrouver des
documents relatifs à l'existence d'un
tel contrat après le décès de l'assuré
qui est généralement soupe scripteur le
bénéficiaire ne n'est pas réellement en
mesure d'en avoir connaissance
on nous a indiqué que
montant des sommes qui sont en jeu varie
entre 700 millions d'euros et 5
milliards d'euros
c'est quand même pas une taille même si
en pourcentage sa part est mineur par
rapport aux 12 165 milliards d'euros qui
constitue l'encours de l'assurance vie
c'est quand même le dire le l'importance
considérable du dossier et l'enjeu
juridique et financier est effectivement
tout à fait primordiale pour un
placement qui est le placement préféré
des français
nous considérons donc il était tout à
fait indispensable de compléter les
dispositions actuelles sur l'assurance
vie
les deux dispositions principales nous
en partageons pleinement les objectifs
l'obligation pour les assureurs de
s'informer au moins annuellement
d'éventuels décès de l'assuré
sans mettre à la charge des assurés
quand même ou des bénéficiaires
l'écoutent de recherche qui eût
constitué un comble et en second lieu
l'obligation de dresser chaque année
pour les assureurs un état de leur
démarche
ce qui là aussi paraît la moindre des
choses pour rechercher les assurés des
cds et les bénéficiaires donc en
considération de ces éléments nous
voterons cette proposition de loi et je
constate qu'il est souvent reproché au
législateur de trop légiférer j'ai déjà
dit moi même plusieurs fois et de
légiférer
trop souvent en l'espèce si le
législateur est obligé de légiférer
c'est en raison des errements constatés
dans le comportement des assureurs mais
je crois qu'il faut le dire très
clairement parce que c'est la réalité et
ça porte sur des sommes qui sont
absolument considérable puisque ce sont
des milliards d'euros alors réjouir
réjouissons-nous d'avoir l'occasion de
légiférer sur un tel dossier et c'est
pourquoi encore une fois nous voterons
cette proposition sur le rapport de la
commission de l'eau
à l'unanimité des membres d'autres
groupes mais si monsieur le sénateur la
parole est à madame catherine troendle
pour le groupe ump
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
sans doute est il devenu un lieu commun
que d'affirmer que les contrats
d'assurance sur la vie et le placement
préféré des français
les chiffres sont là comme l'a rappelé
notre rapporteur monsieur dominique de
legge pour attester de la faveur de nos
concitoyens pour cet instrument
financier qui par sa souplesse peut être
utilisée tant pour préparer sa retraite
que pour opérer un placement à moyen
terme ou encore pour transmettre une
somme d'argent en franchise de droits
pour autant la législation applicable
aux contrats d'assurance sur la vie
suscite certaines difficultés pratiques
récurrentes malgré les avancées
intervenues à l'occasion des lois de
décembre 2005 et décembre 2007
or et les nécessaire d'éviter que ces
difficultés ternissent la confiance
qu'ont les français dans cet instrument
c'est pourquoi le groupe ump salue
l'initiative de monsieur hervé maurey
qui permet de poursuivre nos efforts
pour la résorption du phénomène des
contrats non réclamés par leurs
bénéficiaires en effet trop nombreux
sont encore les contrats qui peuvent ne
pas être mise en exécution au décès de
leurs souscripteurs
contrairement à ce qui était prévu dans
la loi la combinaison des règles
juridiques et l'ancienneté des contrats
d'assurance vie ont entraîné au fil des
décennies la constitution d'un stock
très important de contrats 10 ans d'eddy
en déshérence qui sont arrivées à leur
terme sans qu'aucun des up des acteurs
en présence n'agissent le souscripteur
ne donne plus signe de vie
mais l'assurance n'a pas la preuve qu'il
est décédé
aucun bénéficiaire ne se manifeste comme
l'a souligné notre rapporteur la
totalité des contrats non réclamés
pourrait atteindre dès
qui sans qu'il soit possible à ce jour
d'en évaluer le montant exact ne sont
pas négligeables
dès lors trouver leurs bénéficiaires
permettrait de dénouer ces contrats de
libérer les fonds qui s'y sont accumulés
et de soutenir utilement l'effort de
consommation dans la mesure où ils ne
sont pas immédiatement réinvesti dans de
nouveaux contrats de ses réflexions
étaient nés en 2005 un interlocuteur
unique pour les citoyens en matière
d'assurance-vie l'agira après plusieurs
années d'existence cet organisme a
permis de répondre à bon nombre de
demandes de versement du le
fonctionnement de l'agira mais aussi les
travaux des compagnies d'assurances dote
d'un cadre satisfaisant pour envisager
comme le propose notre rapporteur
l'obligation annuelle pour les assureurs
de s'informer de l'éventuel décès de
l'assureur l'assuré pardon tout en
excluant la possibilité d'imputer leurs
frais de recherche sur les sommes devant
revenir aux bénéficiaires
le groupe ump est satisfait de cette
proposition
en effet compte tenu des sommes en jeu
et de la responsabilité qui incombe à
l'assureur de rechercher les
bénéficiaires des contrats qu'il
commercialise
il est raisonnable d'écarter toute
possibilité d'imputer ces frais sur les
sommes versées ainsi que la possibilité
de créer une profession à gré enfin il
est impératif de ne pas transformer ce
sujet en aubaine commerciale pour des
entreprises plus soucieuse de chiffre
d'affaires que de l'intérêt des
héritiers qui souvent très heureux de
toucher un héritage inattendu se laisse
imposer une commission parfois
exorbitantes
parallèlement il était indispensable
comme l'a envisagé la commission des
lois de prévoir l'obligation pour les
assureurs de dresser chaque année un
état de leurs démarches de recherche d
assurer des cd et des bénéficiaires tout
en respectant les dispositifs adoptés
successivement en 2005 et 2007
la commission des lois a su maintenir l'
équilibre entre respect des droits des
assurés et moyens mis à leur dit
position des entreprises d'assurances
pour assumer leurs responsabilités entre
attractivité des contrats d'assurance
sur la vie et obligations qui sont
attachés entre liberté contractuelle et
contraintes légales
c'est pourquoi le groupe ump votre à
cette proposition de loi
merci madame à son actrice la parole est
un monsieur jean pierre sueur pour le
groupe socialiste
madame la présidente ce monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
s'agissant des assurances il ne vous
étonnera pas que je dise d'abord
quelques mots de la loi du 18 décembre
cette loi comporte vous le savez
puisqu'elle a été adopté à l'unanimité
un article sur les contrats obsèques et
elle dispose que les sommes versées au
titre des contrats obsèques sont vraies
revalorisé chaque année du montant de
l'est plus taux d'intérêt légal
c'est simple c'est clair ça a été
adoptée à l'unanimité par le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale
moins de deux mois plus tard monsieur le
ministre
une ordonnance apparaissait émanant de
votre ministère qui rayer d'un trait de
plume
cet article nous avons bien entendu été
choqués du procédé et derechef le sénat
et l'assemblée nationale ont voté à
l'unanimité la même disposition car il y
avait là un usage très choquant de cette
ordonnance
dont je n'ai jamais su et jamais pu
comprendre d'où elle venait
qui avait eu l'idée saugrenue de retirer
cet article or comme je suis ce sujet
monsieur le ministre avec une grande
attention
je constate aujourd'hui que cet article
de loi n'est toujours pas appliquée or
il est application directe aucun décret
n'est nécessaire vous comprendrez donc
monsieur le ministre que j'ai une
question simple à vous poser monsieur le
ministre est partisan du fait que le
gouvernement doit veiller à
l'application de la loi et qu'allez vous
faire pour que cette loi soit appliquée
comme elle trois lettres
en second lieu je voudrais moi aussi me
réjouir de l'excellente proposition de
loi de notre collègue hervé maurey ce
texte était nécessaire
l'enjeu financier des contrats
d'assurance sur la vie en déshérence
n'est pas mince puisqu'il s'agit de 1 à
5 milliards d'euros selon les sources
la proposition de loi tend à renforcer
les obligations des assureurs dans la
recherche des bénéficiaires de ces
contrats en rente annuelle l'obligation
de s'informer sur le décès éventuel du
souscripteur est aussi en termes de
transparence sur les encours concernés
l'effectivité des recherches entreprises
nous soutenons comme l'a excellemment
10e madame virginie klès ce cette
proposition que nous voterons pour au
moins deux raisons monsieur mort et la
première qu'elle est morale puisqu'elle
tiens tu avais la volonté du contractant
l'autre économique qui tient à
l'inefficacité des sommes ainsi
mobilisés d'une part ces sommes doivent
être mises à la disposition des
bénéficiaires de ces contrats
conformément à la volonté des
souscripteurs
d'autre part ces sommes doivent être
réinjectés dans l'économie surtout dans
les temps qui courent
pour participer au développement de
l'activité et de notre économie
je veux saluer les amendements apportés
par la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur
je crois que ces amendements sont tout à
fait positif et je rappelle en cette
circonstance notre accord le monsieur le
rapporteur avec la suppression de
l'article iv de la proposition initiale
qui proposait qui aboutissait même si
tel n'était pas l'intention de monsieur
mort et mais qui aboutissait à défaire
l'equilibre défini par la loi du 17
décembre 2007 l' équilibre implique que
l'acceptation par les bénéficiaires qui
rend l'accord de celui-ci obligatoire
pour tous rachats aux modifications ne
peut se faire qu'avec le consentement
des stimulants et la livre évocation par
le souscripteur de l'acceptation par le
bénéficiaire qui était prévu par le
texte initial ouvrait en effet la porte
à une requalification en simple contrat
de capitelles capitalisation du contrat
d'assurance sur la vie
nous pensons que la transparence est
toujours bonne sauf dans quelques
domaines
nous ne sommes pas pour l'abolition du
secret défense encore que quelquefois il
soit très facilement invoquée est trop
facilement invoquée est à cet égard il
nous paraît sage que l'on puisse
connaître quels sont les contrats qui
n'ont pas été honorées qui n'ont pas été
réclamés après la mort du défunt de la
personne qui a cessé de vivre
et aussi quelles sont les encours en
cause et c'est pour le prolonger
l'action dans ce sens que nous avons
déposés monsieur le ministre un
sous-amendement il nous paraît simple
clair transparent bénéfique que
finalement on puisse savoir chaque année
que chaque compagnie d'assurances où
chaque organisme compétent
puis chaque année dire combien il y a
deux contrats qui n'ont pas été réclamés
et quelle somme qu'elle en cours cela
constitue voilà la proposition
complémentaire que nous nous permettrons
de faire tout en soulignant à nouveau
comme l'a fait virginie klès le conte
bien eu ce texte est positif la parole
est à madame catherine procaccia pour
l'ump
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
lorsque mon assistante m'a signalé qu'un
texte sur les contrats d'assurance vie
étaient inscrits à l'ordre du jour ce
jeudi 29 avril
je me suis demandé pourquoi et encore
encore et pourquoi puisque le sénat a
été dans ces dernières années à la
pointe dans ce domaine et je n'ai pas le
sentiment que sous la houlette de
philippe marini en 2005 sur la dd
assainies sous celle de jean jacques
hyest
en 2007 nous ayons mal travaillé bien au
contraire et j'associe à ces travaux
notre collègue yves detraigne puisque
tous les deux nous avons été là au cours
de ces années
non seulement nous avons réellement fait
avancer les choses en assurant une
réelle information des assurés mais
surtout nous avons créé les bases
durables et efficaces qui permettent
dorénavant aux assureurs d'accéder au
fichier des personnes décédées ce qu'il
ne pouvait pas faire jusqu'en 2009
sans cet accès je ne vois pas comment
les assureurs pouvait découvrir qu'un de
leurs assurés étaient décédés sauf peut
être s'il avait dépassé les 110 ans
d'ailleurs je doute que les banques se
pose ce type de questions si un compte
de son mouvement
elles ne bougeront que lorsque le conte
sera découvert ce qui m'amène à me
demander mais à vous demander aussi
monsieur le ministre ce qu'il devient
des sommes des comptes bancaires ou de
ce livret d'epargne que nous offrons à
la naissance des enfants
même si les sommes sont peut-être plus
faibles comme l'assurance vie
y at il une procédure en ce domaine en
lisant le rapport de notre collègue
dominique de legge
j'ai été rassuré il ne remettait pas en
cause le travail législatif antérieures
qu'il connaissait parfaitement lui aussi
et s'était interrogé sur l'opportunité
de modifier un système restants qui
commence tout juste à être opérationnels
hervé maurey a souligné son pragmatisme
je m'y associe parce que je crois qu'en
matière d'assurance que ce soit vis ou
autre il faut plus de pragmatisme que
d'idéologie les contrats en déshérence
sont un sujet
atik qui fait facilement la une des
journaux ils sont notre monstre du loch
ness notre nestea il y aurait des
millions voire des milliards ignore et
d'euros ignoré par des bénéficiaires qui
dormiraient comme au fond du lac
mais pour l'instant c'est millions oc
milliards personne ne les a vus et le
monstre du loch ness n'est peut-être
qu'un gros sauts rien qui nous faire
rêver
n'aurions nous pas quelque part un oncle
ou une cousine richissime dont nous
serions les rites et équins gens qui
généalogistes va nous retrouver nous
avertir les assureurs ne sont pas
irréprochables car avant ce 21ème siècle
peut se sont préoccupés de ces contrats
dorment en avant nos interventions
législatives mais les assurés ne le sont
pas non plus et je veux profiter de
cette tribune pour faire part d'al avis
tout à fait personnel et de mon
étonnement parce que nous faisons preuve
de beaucoup de sollicitude l'italie de
personnes qui finalement ne se préoccupe
pas du capital qu'il place et qui leur
rapportent des intérêts pour ma part moi
qui souscrit depuis que j'ai commencé à
travailler je sais même si ces sommes ne
sont pas de 2000 euros où elles sont et
qu'ils en aient les bénéficiaires je
trouve que c'est quand même faire preuve
de beaucoup de négligence
et si certains assurés sont trop vieux
pour se souvenir qu'ils ont souscrit des
contrats
tous ne peuvent pas être dans ce cas
notre collègue hervé maurey me paraît
donc avoir été bien confiant en croyant
qu'un courrier pourrait faire bouger
c'est négligent j'approuve donc la
sagesse de la commission qui a supprimé
la référence à l'accusé de réception car
une non réponse aurait été plus souvent
dus à la négligence qu'au décès et aux
arrêtés lourdes coupes de gestion pour
nous les assurés c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais avoir des précisions sur les
dispositions que la commission a intégré
à l'article 1
concernant la recherche annuel qui va
fixer les modalités pratiques de cette
recherche sera t-elle obligatoire dans
tous les cas même si l'assuré a eu un
contact dans l'année pour deux lotos ou
pour de l'habitation avec une banque
avec son assureur ou si la banque auprès
de laquelle elle a été souscrite
l'assurance vie
ce qui est la majorité des cas de
l'assurance gère aussi des comptes
bancaires de la personne je sais que les
assureurs monsieur le rapporteur ont
accepté cette procédure mais il faut
être lucide ce sont nous assurer qu'ils
paieront les frais de cette gestion
supplémentaires alors autant la limiter
aux seules personnes qui ont vu aucun
contact avec une entreprise gestionnaire
pourriez vous ou l'un ou l'autre m'a
apporté des précisions sur ce sujet et
comme je suis fidèle à mes convictions
que j'aime et vous le savez chers
collègues de la suite dans les idées
je regrette que la commission n'ait pas
retenu deux éléments de la ppl de notre
collègue hervé maurey car ses
dispositions je les avait défendus en
2005 ou en 2007
la première concerne la communication
obligatoire annuelle du souscripteur du
contrat d'assurance vie lui rappeler
qu'il doit informer son assureur de son
déménagement et qu'il peut modifier ou
compléter la clause bénéficiaire
faciliterait bien les choses il me
semble cependant que les assureurs
pourraient de même prendre cette
initiative qui permettrait de tenir un
jour leurs fichiers il suffit peut-être
monsieur le ministre de leur suggérer
avec insistance
la seconde concerne le caractère
irrévocable de l'acceptation de la
clause bénéficiaire
certes depuis la loi de 2007 les assurés
sont maintenant clairement prévenu sur
leur contrat est acceptée et peuvent
leurs proches refusé mais en meilleur
t-il toujours les conséquences ce
principe me paraît contraire à tout ce
que nous votons pour améliorer la
protection d'assurer et me paraît
dépassé un siècle ou un mariage sur
trois se termine par un divorce ou une
libéralité accordé à l'âge de 30 ans
peut vous contraindre pendant 50 ou 60
ans eu égard à l'allongement de la durée
de la vie je continue donc mais
maintenant nous sommes deux à contester
l'existence de cette clause dans les
contrats d'assurance vie c'est la fin de
cette séance merci de l'avoir suivi pour
la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr bonne journée à tous sur
public sénat